from neandertals to lucy
discoveries of ancient hominids give us
a window into the past
but it's been a challenge for
researchers to figure out exactly how we
evolved from our more distant ancestors
who lived over 7 million years ago
a recent review in science traces how
fossil apes have
bolstered our understanding of human
origins
and what steps we can take to learn even
more
some paleontologists have interpreted
living african apes
as time capsules of myosin apes that
roamed the earth from 5
to 23 million years ago but this limits
the narratives of how we came to be
there are four lineages of living apes
chimpanzees gorillas orangutans
and gibbons many other lineages of apes
thrive during the miocene
but around 8 to 9 million years ago the
climate shifted from
warm widespread tropical forests
to cooler fragmented habitats this major
climatic shift
likely caused the extinction of many
myosin ape lineages
the over-reliance on living apes to
study humans
has stunted evolutionary theories
including how humans evolved bipedalism
the ability to walk on two hind feet
initially
researchers thought that humans were
able to walk on land
due to an adaptation from living apes an
upright posture developed from hanging
on branches all day
but fossil apes like pirilopithecus
catalaunicas
discovered in spain lacked the long
hands and curved fingers
tailored to dangling from trees
still the structure of its body showed
it had erect posture
which could have helped it climb trees
vertically this suggests that upright
posture
could have been the starting point for
bipedalism
instead of hanging ability a theory that
could not have emerged from studying
living apes alone
combining our knowledge of living and
fossil apes
could spark a revolution in how we see
our evolution
one step is expanding paleontological
survey sites
many mid to late miocene apes have been
discovered throughout europe
but fewer have been uncovered from that
time period in africa
where limited road access and dense
forests cover potential study locations
scientists still hope to discover fossil
apes that are more closely related to
gorillas and chimpanzees
as well as those that survived the major
climatic shift
in the late miocene new analytical
techniques
also provide more insight into specimens
that were already discovered
currently scientists can analyze ancient
proteins from bone and teeth
up to 2 million years old this helped
unveil that gigantopithecus
a specimen thought to be an ancestor of
gorillas
was more closely related to orangutans
3d scans of fossils will add even more
dimensions to these cross species
comparisons
lastly tracking living apes motions with
cameras
instead of describing them will help
pinpoint the link
between their movement and physical
traits
these steps will bring us closer to
grasping the astounding diversity
of the miocene's planet of the apes
you